prosecutors showed this video to a grand
jury leading the panel to indict New
Orleans Saints running back Alvin Kamara
Cincinnati Bengals cornerback Chris
lemons and two other men for battery now
their surveillance is from cameras in a
hallway outside of drays after dark in
the basement of the Cromwell of course
that's on the Strip a witness describing
what you just saw there as a rush of
people and then several men in that
group stomping and hitting that victim
this entire incident lasting just about
15-20 seconds or so you see more people
pull that group away and then they all
leave in a limo now in that limo
prosecutors say Kamara told the group
quote I connected with the expletives
jaw so hard the victim suffering several
injuries including a broken eye socket
he also had shoulder surgery and is
suing Kamara in civil court for 10
million dollars Kamara lemons and the
two other men identified in court
transcripts as kamara's manager All
Phase battery in conspiracy to commit
battery charges kamara's attorney saying
in part their client intends to fight
these allegations at trial they say he
was defending himself and others during
that video you just saw they do so
investigators also learning detectives
work to identify the men from a copy of
kamara's receipt at the club all four
men do in court next week